[Música]
en Colombia el gobierno del presidente
Gustavo Petro y la guerrilla del Ln
anunciaron que retoman los diálogos de
paz a partir del mes de noviembre tras
varios años de suspensión Cuba y
Venezuela y Noruega serán los países
garantes del proceso que recibió el
visto bueno de Naciones Unidas
el ex presidente de Estados Unidos o
Donald Trump me pidió a la Corte Suprema
intervenir para bloquear la
investigación desde el departamento de
justicia en su contra por sustraer
documentos clasificados de la Casa
Blanca los archivos fueron hallados en
un reciente registro del FBI a su
mansión de la Florida Mara al lago
Tenemos reporte
y Twitter aceptó la oferta del
multimillonario elon mosque que propuso
seguir adelante con su propuesta
original de comprar en la red social por
44 mil millones de dólares ante la
noticia las acciones de la empresa se
dispararon en la bolsa de valores de
Nueva York
Estas son las noticias de América en
francés 24 y comenzamos el secretario
general de Naciones Unidas Antonio
Gutiérrez aplaudió el anuncio del
gobierno de Colombia liderado por
Gustavo Petro y la guerrilla del Ln las
partes anunciaron la reanudación de las
negociaciones con miras a la paz luego
de más de tres años desde la disolución
de la mesa de negociaciones durante el
mandato del ex presidente Iván Duque el
gobierno y los líderes del grupo
guerrillero volverán a charlar en la
primera semana de noviembre Cuba Noruega
y Venezuela serán los países garantes
el diálogo se reanuda desde Caracas el
gobierno colombiano y la guerrilla de
lln anunciaron que restablecerán las
conversaciones de Paz El próximo mes
pensamos que en esta oportunidad las
nuevas circunstancias políticas de
Colombia han permitido reiniciar las
negociaciones
entonces la confianza que tenemos ahora
es que hay un viraje en la política de
paz que históricamente ha tenido
Colombia la delegación del gobierno
colombiano aseguró que hay evidencias de
que el eln ha reducido sus actividades
en muchos territorios y se mostró
optimista con la intención de acabar con
los enfrentamientos armados por parte de
la guerrilla las condiciones están ahí
Ese es el marco de nuestro diálogo la
transparencia
cualquier cosa que se acuerde es entre
las partes
y lo que se va acordando se va
cumpliendo el diálogo en sí mismo debe
expresar los cambios y esta delegación
de paz nos ha expresado y nos ha dado
elementos de profunda confianza la
primera mesa de negociaciones cayó en
2019 cuando el expresidente derechista
Iván Duque ordenó su disolución después
de un atentado perpetrado por el Ln en
una escuela de policía en la capital
Bogotá más de tres años después la gran
incógnita es si verdaderamente es viable
que a pesar del tiempo transcurrido y
los cambios dentro de la guerrilla y en
el propio país se podrán aprovechar los
pasos avanzados en el pasado Bueno lo
primero importante es que ya hay una
metodología que se avanzó en el gobierno
de Santos ya hay unos puntos que se
limitaron en el gobierno de Santos y ya
hay un camino que se ha avanzado no
vamos a arrancar de Cero y eso va a
ahorrar mucho tiempo en la negociación
Cuba Noruega de Venezuela serán los
garantes y sedes del nuevo proceso
[Aplausos]
ya son 16 las víctimas mortales que dejó
el motín en la prisión de latacunga en
Ecuador el hecho también dejó hasta el
momento 43 personas heridas que tuvieron
que recibir atención médica Ecuador vive
desde hace meses una escalada de
violencia en los centros penitenciarios
que ha sido imposible de detener el
sistema penitenciario de Ecuador es
nuevamente epicentro de violencia un
enfrentamiento se desató entre presos
armados con pistolas y cuchillos dentro
de la prisión de latacunga ubicada a
unos 80 kilómetros de quito la capital
del país el motín inició en la madrugada
del lunes 3 de septiembre y se mantuvo
durante varias horas del martes mientras
las autoridades lograron controlar la
situación dejando un saldo lamentable
como resultado de estos hechos se
registra al momento 43 personas heridas
y 16 fallecidas de las cuales 14
personas han sido identificadas luego de
las pericias efectuadas por el personal
de criminalística y Policía Nacional
según las autoridades los
enfrentamientos iniciaron cuando los
presos participaban del censo
penitenciario ecuatoriano el gobierno
central atribuye los hechos
principalmente a las luchas entre bandas
por el control de las rutas del
narcotráfico y confirmaron que Leandro
norero considerado uno de los
principales narcotraficantes del país se
encuentra entre los fallecidos los
familiares de los reclusos exigen
respuestas
uno no se puede dormir en paz no cae ni
hambre ni sé sabiendo que lo que está
pasando aquí es una desesperación grande
para toda la familia
tormento adentro adentro
se nos Busca todo nos ven todo y porque
les armamentos están dentro a pesar de
que el gobierno anunció mejoras en la
seguridad de las cárceles este incidente
es apenas el más reciente en medio de la
oleada de violencia en los centros
penitenciarios del país solo en 2021 al
menos 300 presos murieron en medio de
motines carcelarios en Ecuador
en noticias de Estados Unidos el
expresidente de Donald Trump solicitó
Este martes al tribunal supremo del país
que intervenga en el caso de Mara lago
su residencia de Florida que fue
registrada y donde el FBI incautó
documentos clasificados de la Casa
Blanca los detalles con nuestro
corresponsal en Washington Cristóbal
Vázquez
sí le pidió específicamente a la Corte
Suprema de Justicia de Estados Unidos
que empezó la sesión de invierno ayer
precisamente que le permita a el
encargado especial de la revisión de los
documentos que fueron allanados en su
mansión de Lago en la Florida que pueda
revisar 100 documentos que fueron
confiscados precisamente de la mansión y
que son catalogados como confidenciales
con esto lo que dicen expertos legales
Es que él era el presidente del ex
presidente Donald Trump Busca demorar el
proceso esto precisamente porque hace
unos días una corte de apelaciones pues
tumbó la posibilidad de que no se
pudiera usar este contenido que fue
allanado que fue rescatado de la mansión
de Mara lago en contra de el ex
presidente en contra de la investigación
Precisamente en esta investigación que
se adelanta por que el ex presidente se
llevó de la Casa Blanca documentos
confidenciales es de Resaltar sin
embargo que
el corte conservador en el en el en el
en el máximo órgano legislativo de
Estados Unidos como es la Corte Suprema
es de corte conservador es decir hay que
recordar que Donald Trump hizo elegir a
tres magistrados de la Corte Suprema
durante sus últimos donde durante su
última administración esto le da cierta
ventaja sin embargo el presidente está
en su contra ya Donald Trump había
solicitado ciertas interferencias
precisamente de la Corte Suprema de
Justicia a favor de él pero la corte a
pues
ha dado órdenes en contra de el ex
presidente y de que él y de que la corte
termina interfiriendo a favor de los
procesos que se adelantan en contra de
Donald Trump
y solo tres meses después de haber
renunciado a comprar la red social
Twitter el multimillonario de elon mosco
ofreció pagar el mismo monto que había
acordado con la otra parte 44 mil
millones de dólares
nuevo giro de 180 grados para el hombre
más rico del planeta
informó en una carta enviada Twitter de
su intención de comprar la compañía al
precio inicial acordado en abril es
decir 44 mil millones de dólares esta
decisión llega dos semanas antes del
inicio del juicio que opone las dos
partes en abril el director general de
tesla firmó la compra de Twitter pero
poco tiempo después con célula operación
acusando a la red de mentir sobre el
número de cuentas falsas en respuesta
Twitter lanzó un procedimiento judicial
contra el multimillonario creo que mosc
con la batalla judicial de Delaware que
se avecina reconoció que iba a ser muy
complicado él iba a terminar teniendo
que poseer Twitter de una manera u otra
le ahorró una fea batalla judicial que
estaba prevista para el 17 de octubre
los cargos judiciales en su contra pero
Twitter esperará que la transacción sea
completada antes de hacerlo Twitter
obviamente quiere cerrarlo quiere tomar
54,20 dólares por acción pero no creo
que va a estar dispuesta a poner fin a
los procedimientos en la cancillería de
Delaware hasta que tenga algún tipo de
garantía absoluta de que esto es
realmente honesto tras el anuncio la
acotación de la acción Twitter subió un
22% de concretarse la transacción una de
las plataformas de mayor influencia en
el mundo de las redes sociales quedaría
en manos de mezcla el empresario
contempla privatizar Twitter y sacarla
de la bolsa para tener más margen de
maniobra también espera flexibilizar la
moderación de contenido considera que la
prohibición permanente de usuarios no es
la solución pero lo que más preocupa a
los usuarios es la protección de datos
más información también la encuentra en
France 24.com siga con nosotros
[Música]